what about the argument that people get
pregnant by rape or by incest so
where do you stand on those issues and
incest are obviously horrific cases
i am completely for advocating for that
that girl for that woman you know she
deserves
the very best support and help but then
do we take out the penalty of that rape
on this child who's conceived in
violence
in the u.s we don't even give the death
penalty to rapists and when you look at
women who are survivors of
who may get pregnant telling her oh have
an abortion that's not going to take
away the trauma of her rape
in fact it can add only more trauma
because now you're not only
a victim and a survivor of rape but now
she's going to be a victim of an
abortion herself
because she is going to be told to
commit this violent act
against her child to kill that child now
and also against her body
so abortion is not the answer and we
have to do better for both
the woman and for that child who might
be conceived that way